heute vormittag in düsseldorf schnell
noch einmal tanken bevor die preise
wieder richtig hoch gehen
20 steigen und dann noch die ganzen
anderen kosten das ist natürlich schon
heftig man hat daraus ein anderen
ausgaben man versucht das mitzunehmen
was man kann ich hoffe nicht dass das so
extrem steigen wird dass man sich das
noch einigermaßen leisten kann so haben
sich die spritpreise in den letzten drei
monaten entwickelt und man sieht schon
kurz vor auslaufen des tank rabatt
ziehen die preise wieder an auf den
weltmarkt und gestiegene transportkosten
verweist die mineralölindustrie
doch kritiker halten entgegen dass das
nur minimale preisanstiege rechtfertigen
insofern rechtfertigt das nicht die
preissprünge die wir jetzt sogar schon
vor dem ende des tank rabatt wieder
sehen dass es aus unserer sicht nicht
gerechtfertigt sondern hier versuchen
die konzerne wieder ein stück weit einen
puffer sich in die eigene tasche zu
stecken was ist an den vorwürfen dran
der markt ist schwer zu durchschauen
auch weil eine handvoll von konzernen
die ganze lieferkette kontrolliert
raffinerien tanklager tankstellen das
bundeskartellamt untersucht zurzeit die
preisgestaltung der konzerne
dann müssen wir im moment einfach zur
kenntnis nehmen ja es gibt eine reihe
von umständen die führen dazu dass die
mineralstoffe teurer werden wir haben
ausfälle in raffinerien und in anderen
bereichen aber wir wissen eben auch
dass wir es mit einem markt zu tun haben
auf dem der wettbewerb nur gedämpft
funktioniert und deswegen schauen wir
eben sehr genau hin und
untersuchen ob hier möglicherweise in
den hohen preisen auch ein ganz kleiner
teil oder ein teil
ein missbrauch ist nein man arbeite nach
den regeln des marktes und habe auch den
tank rabatt komplett weitergegeben wird
sich die branche und so sei klar dass
man nun auch den anstieg der energie
steuer auf das alte level weiter geben
werde 35 cent mehr pro liter benzin und
17 cent mehr pro liter diesel was wir
aber nicht wissen ist wie verhält sich
der autofahrer wie wird sich die
autofahrerin tankt sie uns die
tankstellen quasi leer vor dem 31 august
oder gibt es am ersten september noch
restmengen niedrig versteuerten benzin
und diesel so dass da noch die preise
niedrig sind das wissen wir erst wenn es
soweit ist es kann also sein dass die
preise ab dem ersten september nicht
sprunghaft sondern graduell steigen aber
deutlich teurer wird es so viel ist
sicher